hay algo más inalcanzable que un amor
platónico creo que solo lasa síntomas
pero que son las síntomas son líneas
inalcanzables para una gráfica esta
gráfica por mucha que la sigamos
trazando trazando y trazando nunca va a
tocar a su asiento está va a estar muy
cerca pero no la tocara justo como si
fueras amor platónico
las funciones que tienen este rollo de
amores platónicos o dicho
matemáticamente de assín total son las
racionales en el lugar de la pei la q
vamos a encontrar polinomios en una
división como fx igual a equis cuadrada
menos 3x menos dos entre x cuadrada
menos 4
desde que vemos este tipo de funciones
ya huele a síntomas porque tenemos una x
en el divisor siempre que hay divisiones
que involucren la incógnita habrá
números en el dominio de la función que
no podremos utilizar
cuando hay división el dominio no
permite valores para que exista una
división entre cero ya que eso es una
indeterminación y aquí es donde
encontramos nuestra cinta
en la función que tenemos los resultados
con los que el divisor se vuelve 0 es
con dos y menos dos porque al cuadrado
ambas dan 4 y 4 - 4 es cero
entonces aquí tenemos dos amores
platónicos hay dos puntos que no podemos
tocar por más que nos acerquemos
tendremos a síntomas cuando x vale 2 y
cuando vale menos 2 veamos la gráfica de
esta función para comprobarlo
wow incluso la gráfica se acorta en esos
puntos
si trazamos líneas a la altura de dos y
menos dos parece que toca en la gráfica
pero no ningún punto estará ubicado en
esas líneas te lo puedo asegurar estas
líneas o zonas por las que nunca pasará
la gráfica nos ayudan a saber qué
valores no son posibles para la función
y por lo tanto hacia donde tiende el
límite de la función con esos valores
recuerda que esas zonas prohibidas en
las funciones se llaman a sin todas y si
las tocas algo está mal en tu ejercicio
son tan payasas que no dejan que nadie
se les acerque demasiado